let's
let's start with patrick mahomes though
because
clearly in the concussion protocol that
was never going to be a doubt there's no
way he was getting back in the game
after he struggled to get off the ground
on a play where i've watched it 10 times
i still don't see right
the type of blow to the head no
concussed someone right there wasn't
helmeted helmet right it didn't look
like he landed forcibly on the ground
with his helmet i don't even think his
head he got him on
i it's almost like yeah it was almost
like induced by a blow to the neck i
agree thank you
right we were texting about this
yesterday during the game right i mean
you know but of course we both love my
homes but i'm with you it just again i
mean
he obviously was concussed but it was
very odd because you were just like wait
i don't know where he really got hit in
the head or you know of course when you
see a guy stand up and go wobbly in
their knee go to like rubber you know
that's usually see a really
forcible big time shot to the head and
and that that's where it was odd to me
too and like you said i don't think his
head even ever touched the ground
because if you watch the replay i went
back in dvr the ball was like tucked
underneath his chin
and it actually like never even got to
the ground his head i think i don't even
think it hit the ground so
i'm with you i think it might have been
like that left
arm of the defender in his neck area and
that was scary it really was to see a
quarterback out of it like that
yeah i mean you rarely see that kind of
wobbly right from a player much less a
star quarterback and it was obvious that
point he's not coming back in the game
and then he was already dealing with the
toe injury on his left foot you could
see the way he was running and walking
and moving on it he was twisting it to
the inside to put more of the weight on
the rest of his foot not on his big toe
so between the concussion and the toe
and now we've got six days to sunday
that that that's an issue and i had
people texting me last night saying
we're going to see you know the the true
test of the integrity of the nfl's
concussion policy if he plays on sunday
well you know what when they first
started with this hypersensitivity
and justifiable hypersensitivity to
concussions
11 you 12 years ago
there was kind of a presumption that if
you got a concussion
you missed a game
then at some point it shifted to
a lot of these guys if not most of these
guys if not the vast majority make it
back the following week i'm not going to
be surprised if he's cleared by sunday
i'll be i'm not surprised at all yes
yeah
the issue is that toe let's not
underestimate that toe and it could be
that getting out of the game when he did
kept the toe from getting worse than it
otherwise would have been in a weird
sort of way that may promote his ability
to play and be closer to 100 next week
the fact that he was able to get off
that toe and quit doing possible more
damage to it well
first off on the concussion
the the way that what it's gotten i
wasn't so sure we might not see him the
last drive or two of the game i i don't
know i really didn't i mean we've seen
guys be a little wobbly this year and
come back the next series and stuff so
you don't know and a lot of the time i
mean again he did have some wits with
him he was tweeting at the end of the
football game you know and so i i didn't
know where that was gonna go i didn't
expect him to be back you're right
though the toe is an issue i mean
that is a
pain in the butt type of injury right
there it i don't know how other way to
explain it but it's one of those things
where walking running anytime you cut
push off of it anything like that
even though it's just a toe and you want
to be like hey man suck it up it's just
your toe no it is extremely painful it
led to dion sanders retiring i mean
that's how the delicate this situation
could be i do think though just like we
saw
the fact that it's his left foot
will be it'll make him okay it's going
to hurt his mobility he's not going to
be able to run around but we saw
you know other than a throw two throws
to the left you know he'll be able to
sit back on that right leg
and just twist off it and i don't think
it's going to affect his throwing but it
will affect his mobility if he is able
to play which i expect him to and i
expect him to clear concussion protocol
this is a guy we've seen throw the ball
effectively with two feet on the ground
right foot on the ground no feet on the
ground so
i'm not concerned about the throwing i'm
just concerned about what what the
impaired mobility can do to his broader
game right remember last year it was in
the afc championship game one of the key
plays wasn't his throwing it was that
run through and around and between the
titans defenders who were just kind of
standing there looking around at each
other as he ran to the end zone you take
that away from patrick mahomes and you
got a problem and look he's always been
very good at protecting himself when he
runs i don't know was the thinking about
the toad did that make him less able to
protect himself against the hit i think
you can anytime you get tackled that
that's what makes the concussion so
bizarre it just looked like a routine
tackle that's right anytime you get
tackled you could end up with a
concussion
um it's it's it's just it's just
unfortunate it occurred in that spot
[Music]
and he got it done he came in and hey i
i'm not gonna go to sleep on chad and he
had the horrible interception but you
know games on the line
are not i mean they're trying to keep
the they're trying to keep the bra on
the line
yeah it's on the line i mean they hope
would have opened the door for the
browns to possibly do something they go
for it on fourth down and uh
chad henry makes the throw and yeah he
didn't have to throw it 25 yards down
the field in a keyhole but he still made
the throw in that moment he didn't gack
he didn't throw it into the ground he
didn't sail it over tyrek hill's head he
made the throw and they got the first
down so you know henny's been around
he's the guy that would have been the
backup last year when mahomes got
injured and missed a couple of games it
was matt moore instead but henry was on
the injured reserve list so they believe
in him he knows the offense and if if
they have to get it done without patrick
mahomes we've seen in the past that they
can right they they they beat the did
they beat the packers they almost did
they beat your bike
they beat your vikings and almost beat
the packers yes thanks for pointing that
out no problem
one of my favorite jim harbaugh thanks
for pointing that out
thanks for bringing that up yeah long
story i think i've told it before but
let's keep let's stay focused tell your
dad i said hold on yeah let's focus
screw you jim see you later um let's
hear let's hear go ahead go ahead and
say something then we'll hear from andy
reed on going forward on that fourth
well i i mean i just wanted to say like
you know what you're saying about henny
you know just everything
it's the overlooked aspect of the kansas
city chiefs football team sexy air show
highlights awesome no-look passes it's
all amazing
but they're tough this their toughness
and their physicality and their grit won
the game yesterday and they continue to
show that even though as much as we
always talk about ooh i don't know how
great their defense is oh it's just
again oh we gotta stop the browns run
game all right we'll we'll slow it down
no problem we got big guys we got dudes
to do that i'm just always amazed by
that oh we gotta run the ball patrick
mahomes is out we gotta run the ball
against this defense no problem we'll
run it we'll start running it that to me
where just andy reid
it just that's him right there and i got
to give him credit and now let's let's
hear from him okay all right here we go
here's andy reid rolling the dice to ice
the game uh late in the fourth quarter
but i just looked at eb and
asked him
you're ready to roll and he goes
absolutely
mike kafka you ready to roll let's go
joe upstairs and joe was talking about
it before we ever got there
and um and so there was a chance that we
you know we didn't think it would be
with chad running but you know there's a
there's a chance we're a short yardage
coach you got to make a decision and so
um but there was no doubt with anybody
that's the confidence that's the swagger
that's the spirit that you have when
you're the defending champions and you
just believe in everything that you do
and that's important because you know
chris when the browns had the ball
and they're down
but it's a one score game
and they're
they were
starting to drive and they just were
kind of plotting and just kind of taking
their time like they're putting all eggs
in this drive they convert a fourth down
along the way
and then they get to a fourth and nine
and they punt
and that that just was strange to me
because the way you were executing the
drive it was almost like we're putting
everything on this drive so that means
you got to go forward on fourth down
when you're behaving that way because
you you chewed up so much of the clock
early in the drive you go from eight
minutes
right
eight minutes to
yeah before you punt right when you chew
up that much time to get to
fourth and nine on look at this they
they burned almost four minutes to go 12
freaking yards what in the world chris
well you know they they had been driving
the ball
they just went 18 plays for on an eight
minute drive for a touchdown so
this is
the way they were playing the game at
that point and i think with them punting
the ball there i mean i understand that
you know they it's fourth and nine
that's far you're backed up they don't
want to make it a touchdown and we gotta
score a two-point conversion football
game it's chad henny and the chiefs they
figure wait we could stop them and get
the ball back and drive down once again
they've been really moving the ball
pretty consistently
you know ever since the end of the
second quarter
um so i understand that decision i don't
think that's crazy i i mean i i don't i
know their analytics crowd and people
are going to say there's you know that's
wrong and things like that but
i i don't agree with that i think that
it is perfectly fine to punt the ball in
that situation with chad henny at
quarterback having just thrown a dumb
interception and showing no life on the
offensive side of the ball at all really
for the most part
but why aren't you showing greater
urgency then during that drive if your
strategy from a broader standpoint is if
we have to punt back to chad henny we
will why are you chewing up so much time
to move 12 yards and then punt when
you're acting like we're treating this
with eight minutes left as the final
drive of the game that's what confuses
me to help me understand it and you and
anyone else who may be watching here's
kevin stefanski the browns head coach
explaining a couple of controversial
decisions he made in the fourth quarter
yeah all those decisions scott that
that's on me uh so
i should've been better there um
and then you you know there's there's a
cost to those when you do lose those uh
because you're losing eight timeouts so
that's on me
and then you took you had to take one i
think on a third down um just didn't
like the setup before you had to take it
i know we took one on a first down there
later
which
i get miscommunication so unfortunate
and that ultimately is on me
it's on me for not setting that up
better he was talking about a timeout
that was burned on a challenge early in
the fourth quarter that probably
shouldn't have been challenged and then
a timeout that they took later in the in
the game and those two timeouts would
have come in handy when they were trying
to keep the chiefs from
milking the rest of the clock uh and uh
and getting in position to do exactly
what they did ice the game and win by
five it's amazing to see that score 22
to 17.
and and
there was a while there where i thought
holy crap the browns are going to win
this game the br the brown sure are
going to win after the interception yeah
to a wide open carl joseph in the end
zone so wide open that maybe chad henry
thought he was playing for the browns
that day
but
at that moment i thought oh my god the
browns are going to win this game and
then it all fell apart for them fell
apart defense showed up in kansas city
like we've seen it do you know we talk
about mahomes and everybody we don't you
know kansas city and chris jones and
company stop derek henry kansas city and
company we're down by 10 stop jimmy
garoppolo and the 49ers when we need to
oh patrick mahomes is out and on cloud
nine no problem we'll stop we'll step up
nick chubb kareem hump baker mayfield
who've been good we'll slow him down i
mean that that to me
you know was amazing even on the drive i
don't even care on that 18 play
touchdown drive that still was a great
drive i mean that was a great defensive
drive it was just a great offensive
drive too baker mayfield was phenomenal
he made some unreal throws in the game
again stats don't really tell how well
he played that football game and you
know the game as close as it was awesome
to watch glad kansas city won because as
the game went on i found myself rooting
for kansas city because
it was apparent to me they were the
better team when there's a healthy
patrick mahomes they were the better
team and i'm sorry everybody out there i
want to always see the better teams win
in advance because it means better games
this weekend and i can't wait and then a
better super bowl for all of that but as
close as that game was
we know we'll be talking about
north korea and the fumble in the end
zone at the end of the second quarter
boom because that was a big point and
that was a big argument for you and me
on text yesterday
and and we're going to talk about that
coming up but you're right the better
team won because when it looked like the
browns were gonna win
yesterday in the fourth quarter my next
thought was holy crap the bills are
going to the super bowl
right right now we don't know bills are
chief sits up in the air on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports